aber nicht schlagen ich schlage dich
schlagen mit dem schwert schlagen
okay ich mache meine lieben uns noch
beschäftigen hat vor einer belastung hat
gesagt aufnahme bleiben ob auf der bande
jetzt kannst du dich mit ihnen freuen
und herzlich willkommen zurück bei der
show hier und jetzt 100 zucker und jetzt
bitte danke
wenige später auf warte ich jetzt
einfach in denen das was noch kommt
nein halt stopp das ist ein bisschen rum
schön hast du zu verbessern noch ein
feuerzeug dabei war geschlagen
ich schlage dich schlagen mit dem
schwert schlagen
hierzu feuerzeug den aber es kann damit
war alles anstellen
auch etliche regalmeter das war zu
erfahren
weißt du dass ihr auf dem boden das
wolle auch stand alles in flammen auf
dann ist auf einmal ich bin ja das
schauen jetzt fernseh lästig wir wissen
natürlich gewappnet kriegen das feuer
übrigens da ist stellt wenn ich bin mein
will spielen würde und wenn jemand dich
sehen würde die so fällt wie du in
münchen sofort krämer ich sofort wusste
dass die schweizer 143 160 ps ab
wieso tust was du hier irgendwas läuft
gegen rechts gegen das verbrechen das
green keller damals einen platten davon
immer kaputt gegangen apropos vegetation
eigentlich aus alles brett war hier
unten
die sortierten hier begangen
das ok an alle meine abonnenten ja du
hast kein die objekte bestehen
guck mal wie das gericht weiter mit
sie sagen oder die entweder gäste aus
mainz immer raus oder verwüstet ein
zimmer kennt sich wieder der meine
geschwister wieder ach so unterlag das
erklärt einiges so läuft das in der
familie kontrakt mit bohne wieder
überhaupt nicht versiegt wo ist denn
hier im wasser seien immer noch nicht
wie viel wasser hast du denn jedem
gesetzt ich weiß nicht schaden rohrbruch
feuerwehr der trocknungsprozess der
trocknungsprozess ist im tank benötigt
so symmetrisch naja ok es wohin und so
boden bauen
mal
echt unnötig alter durch eine höhlentour
machen oder wie aber wenn ich jetzt
sterben 31 - wer so dumm oder soll ich
einfach was anderes verzaubern was nicht
jemanden da wollte ich ja den einen
zweiten diamanten hast du denn dein
ändert wieso brauchst du in einen
diamanten den kann man auch noch später
machen die kann man auch später machen
gegen später sich noch wiederholen ich
brauche jetzt weil sonst keine
verzaubern
ja es ist meine ganz einfach das erklärt
einiges zur pasta lukas von april oder
pastis
exalead gefragt ob du und dein bauen
alles aufbauen alles aufbauen mit scheiß
weil die beiden scheiße bohlens
augenbrauen zaun vor dem zaun dahin ja
ich mache ja schon vor dem zaun hin
weiterhin doppelte doppelter sonst
springen er hat ja die kommen da wieder
ein wir haben so viele schaaf in der
tasche ja wir brauchen noch mehr von den
tieren ihr auch genannt tür für jetzt
schon ein thema für diese folge haben
die familien angefangen bei den oben
ok das zum thema wir fangen die sachen
jetzt immer früher in die themen thema
was haltet ihr davon wir sind fast alles
fängt an mit was halten sie davon
alles war schlägt mit sofort auch keiner
schlägt sich das kann ich bezeugen
keiner hat sich bislang
türlich türlich türlich man man man
okay du bist vom mikro weg das hat man
schon lee kun guten was haltet ihr von
gezielten job was willst du was habt ihr
euch für das jahr 2013 vorgenommen habt
ich vorgehen okay noch ob du bist jetzt
tot
was hat euch vorgenommen oder bist tot
neuen trainer willst doch noch sterben
bitte beschützen ich den job mich
bestohlen
habt ihr jetzt nur vorgenommen und
gegenseitig zu töten oder wäre der
datacloud mich jetzt auch schon so die
nachhaltig einfach kommen da draußen
dieses thema vorsorge wir müssen bei der
show bleibt das thema schon gesagt was
habt was habt ihr in 2013 so vor was
habt ihr euch so vorgenommen schwer
danach sofort genommen und aschbach
kreml fällt runter meint ihr die ganze
landschaft kaputt oder wie er macht
alles kaputt das steigerte zeit so
laufen alle im kreis ist der einst vor
den nazis kommen verfolge zu zweit wenn
ihr auch schon scheiße gemalt haye will
auch mal einfach hinterher
da ist die kamera fall scheiß auf thema
abgeben
ja die sachen sie den mehrwert
reingekommen alter wenn der infekt ist
ein traum ich nicht zugucken
na ja ich möchte meine diamanten zurück
wow was macht ihn jetzt ich glaube die
teams sind in sachen sind nicht der elbe
ich glaube er hat definitiv die sachen
auf abnormen sachen ja auch ihr weg
fliegen sehen und dann waren sie
plötzlich weg und das war beim leser
dambach dingen ist es vielleicht mit dem
urlaub woher die sachen die man den
diamanten im märz sachen schlagt ihn
nicht weiter ab sonst hätte das wäre
echt asozial er locker in welche
richtung warten jetzt das portal
er war der die festung ja ich werde mir
zeigen sobald ich mein ja man sonst
hätte ich es nie erfahren
ok ich hab' noch die anderen sachen
liebe von mir gestohlen hast hast du
warst doch noch unten bei meinen kirche
wo hast du denn sonst die ganzen sachen
die ganze 60 hier auch bei der nato hat
schon so als er eigentlich ist es schon
so wie es ist mein haus hier so kaputt
dass du das wieder
ich hatte nie was bei deinem haus
gemacht bzw kaputt gemacht habe ich auch
nie gestohlen ich habe gar keine ihnen
was kaputt geilo soli was bei mir allein
vor der aufnahme in die glasscheibe des
masterstudiums ja eine glasscheibe vor
der aufnahme ich habe ja gesagt in der
aufnahme archivbild auf ihren calls blog
ganz schlimme sind das da und wer hat es
allenfalls auf sich ziehen was also soll
ich dir zeige nur die festung ist aber
es ist relativ egal ich schaff das nicht
wenn man verliert er im letzten zwei
minuten
es ist die letzte folge chance zur folge
dass die vorletzte ich kann mich ganz
mit mit erfolgen nun mal glaube sie
werde sehr produktiv und sinnvoll für
alle beteiligten wenn dort ob sein haus
bauen würde und nicht uns unsere
kaputtmachen würde also schlag jetzt nur
mal so als gemeinschaftlichen vorschlag
vor antrag angenommen
ich möchte trotzdem was verzaubern und
ich hab nicht zum verzaubern
hätte ich nicht selbst einmal diamanten
die wir wieder geklaut das
wahrscheinlich du hattest nie diamant
natürlich ich hatte dir machen eine
tolle show
totally sagt der roten schuhe weg
ziemlich einfach weggeschoben
verschollen sind nichts zu sagen ich
möchte mein gewissen haben wenn ich habe
keine diamanten
achso wasser jemand unseren kommentar
geschrieben hatte dass das den fahrer
den ich jetzt meine zum xp farmen dass
der doch in der nähe von phuket
mediahouse noch nichts gesagt
ja wo ist da das nicht ich hab doch
gesucht gehabt dann wird er war einfach
immer recht damit er sich gut fühlt
nicht geschafft mit so vielen leuten
zusammen
das haus hier den fußboden
zurückzunehmen oder hat den fußboden und
ausgebaut
aber wenn ich wollte produktiv sein
ich suche dieses partner weil dann
hätten wir natürlich dort dadurch eine
ziemlich gute leichte xp quelle diesmal
so sagen ja das ist doch noch mal
richtig kompliziert sein
ich gehe hier um und suchte aber müsste
ja eigentlich und wie so ein loch im
boden sein oder sowas in der art und
wissensportal hier habe ich immer noch
nicht verstanden dass steht folgt um
eine landschaft herum ja werden dass da
mach ich was dagegen
das ist einfach hin gebaut als dann muss
das doch da hingebaut man ich das nicht
da hingebaut aber 1000 prozentig alter
kann sich mittlerweile an nichts mehr
erinnern
ich hab das nicht denn gebaut ich glaube
dass wurde generiert als du irgendwas
nicht herausgegangen ist es so dass da
hinten ja das wort hängen wollte da hab
ich das gebäude das normale er aber das
ging ja ich dachte du meinst dass red
box media steht eins und die man fast
das kommt wenn man im netz kommen
zum gleichen wieder raus beziehungsweise
bin ich das nicht ich weiß jetzt eine
schlucht runter ich weiß aber nicht ob
das beim spa ist
erst der schlusssequenz dreifachen toe
ich stehe jetzt noch
das wäre nicht gut so da muss jetzt hier
wieder hochschulen was macht diesen
hatten wir nicht heben auch pascal
werden gar kein thema besucher mit dem
nivea team ich bin opfer folgt knochen
wir hatten ein thema was macht ihr 2013
vorsetzt habe gar keine gesetzt ich
wollte mir lernen aber das ist man sich
jedes jahr
ich hab mir eigentlich fast nie
irgendwelche sachen immer sie sagen
zumindest solche silvester mir sogar
gesagt
denn angetrunken
was das nun auf youtube geplantes könnt
ihr zumindest für könnte zumindest ja
nix anbrennen
ich habe mich auf ich hab gar nichts
geplant ob du darfst auch gerne das
alles hier so machen wie es vorher war
da wo der krieg explodiert ist und nicht
einfach ne director hinsetzen so an
projekten zum beispiel oder was willst
du mit deinem kanal noch so anstellen wo
ich bin ziemlich platt überholen am
besten noch im januar
ach ja gut erwischt wenn ich soll
brawngp überholen hat sich das gab ein
hohes ausgeputzt lena möchte die festung
zeigen ja aber wenn ich jetzt in level
gehe dann sterbe ich ja wahrscheinlich
oder ist zum einen das likely to the pin
39 wo ist denn hier der verdammtes
baumann den alten hafen
komischen tannenwald ich mache das bei
den nächsten aufnahmen direkt am anfang
mit ein bisschen mehr alle in die
kommentare schreiben wo dieser verdammte
bonner ist wo ist er hier am besten
koordiniert die konten kind auch die map
ja natürlich lieber grund am besten da
die genauen koordinaten rausfinden sagen
da da da ist dass porsche wieder aus da
kann man so und so xp viele bauern dann
ist das so und so es ist toll toll toll
toll toll so so so so bei uns kriegen
ist das so
nur doppelt raus sieht ja dass mich ein
anstalt wird der anfang da sieht doch
gut aus weiß ich wie das haus an sich
ist ob das jetzt auch ford ich scheiß
den ich vor kurzem waren da ja nächsten
auf das sieht man ihm kriegen werde aber
gut aber schön aber toll nicht fertig
ich trau mich gar nicht irgendwie was
richtiges zu machen möchte in der
sterbe- und sterben möchte ich nicht
dass es nicht meine leidenschaft der weg
ist ihr auch schon gebaut ich könnte
mich natürlich um faktor um laternen
kümmern oder wie was wir lancieren
wollen wir denn machen so kann man wie
im boden versenkt oder wollen wir so
stehen aufrecht stehen da ich wäre
einfach für einen zaun mit einer fackel
drauf oder also so langsam lösen
einfachen also einfach nur 1 1
also wir können den ganzen weg natürlich
auch ab dann hat man weniger
beinfreiheit ist eben oder bei videos
seien zu viel wald bahnen oder wollen
wir so versenken im boden das wiso
zweier untergraben und dann ein gross
und ein glas drüber
luca
stimmt dass wir auch ganz klar lasst es
im boden machen also ich hab bloß so'n
habe auch ein bisschen glück und glas ob
ich auch da machen wir das jetzt machen
hessischen letzte folge nein das ist die
1 234 vorletzte und wie lange läuft es
schon
sie läuft jetzt seit 16 minuten dann bei
der nächsten feier ganz fehler schöne
laternen aus glas und glaubst